[Music]
the mono outbreak of Highland Park High
was not an accident it was a terrorist
act but who were these creeps ters and
why did they do such jacked-up [ __ ]
[Music]
we've already broken up man we weren't
cheating we will take you break Fischer
break means it's over yeah it's over how
could she just only one party tonight
and we are not updated you guys gonna
have to wait
got to keep the sides to bun race from
Shaq yes I am a bunch
[Music]
one of those Neanderthals turns out to
be contagious then we'd have a
witch-hunt
the Sheep will turn Bucky's bottle how
do you think we're looking at a rare
strain of the mononucleosis virus what
was going on some kind of rainbow party
that's one where all the girls wear the
different looks like so something for
now we're suspending anybody who was at
the party while we determine who's
contagious look Cooper that's my whole
team on your player should have thought
about that for hosting rainbow party
only a matter of time before the hurt
starts worshipping some new play what if
it was us both the power vacuum sees the
Iron Throne is it just me or has like
gotten so much better ever since those
d-bags how'd it go with Bucky he's in
the hospital and he looks like a
Simpsons character he wouldn't hurt
anybody
you're a saint like Jesus mixed with Tom
Hanks first you get the mono and what
you just basic freaking you get the felt
I want it there's no end anymore we're
all equals and then you get the women
we don't we do to people like you we
electrocute your nuts we put a positive
on one and a negative on the other and
we turn it on and we turn it off and we
turn it on and we turn it off and we're
great at it
do you like oral oh yeah
you